In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadium for September 13th, on which we commemorate,
the consecration of the Church of the Anastasis.
On the 13th of the month, we celebrate the vigil of the exaltation of the venerable and life-giving cross,
and the commemoration of the dedication of the Basilica, of the Resurrection.
In thanksgiving for the most praiseworthy conclusion of the Council of Nicaea,
St. Constantine the Great desired to see to the building of a Basilica on Golgotha,
where the redemption of the world was accomplished.
Macarius, the Bishop of Jerusalem, showed him the place remembered in Christian tradition
that had been covered by an embankment, when Hadrian enlarged the city in the year 135.
They excavated the site and found the Holy Sepulchre and the instruments of the Passion,
and they raised over them a magnificent domed edifice.
The dedication of this church took place on the 13th of September in the year 335,
so that its annual commemoration should replace the pagan celebration of Capitoline Jove.
The beauty of the Basilica, built over this most worshipful place,
was such that it became the symbol of the victory of Christianity and a model for every other Christian church.
The Holy Fathers have chosen this day's feast as an occasion for rejoicing in Psalms and hymns and spiritual songs
at the Resurrection of the visible creation accomplished by Christ, in whom all things are renewed,
for renewal and Kenya is the literal meaning of the term used in Greek for the consecration of the church.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God,
have mercy on us and save us.